[Music]
all right you all know that we love
Mickey D up in here oh bro you just said
the name and I tasted the fries yes sir
we love Mickey brainwashing is but did
y'all know that McDonald's has created a
spin-off chain restaurant that they are
cosmic Cosmic what is it what is it okay
is this an Amer # ad no I'm just kidding
a cafe of some sort okay so it's kind of
like a Sonic they're trying to take over
uh trying to fight Starbucks aren't they
really no way I thought that was be Cafe
I think that's a very strong that's what
I heard too though I heard the same
thing just relax I heard the same thing
yeah I thought it was like you know what
we're going to start we're going to
tackle another [__] industry now well
I see a lot of Starbucks shutting down
so you don't have to worry too much
McDonald themselves they're competing
with each other across the street that's
true okay so a press release
by McDonald's earlier this week
described Cosmic as quote a new small
format beverage Le concept that's truly
out of this world inspired by Nostalgia
and powered by a menu of bold refreshing
Beverages and tasty treats Cosmic is
landing earthside for us humans to enjoy
Cosmic seamlessly Blends brand new
otherworldly beverage creations with a
small lineup of food including a select
few McDonald's favorites thank God all
designed to boost your mood into the
stratosphere if only for a few moments
it does kind of feel like Sonic that's
what I'm saying yeah but why why do they
come out of roller blades it's
drive-thru only do they come out with
roller blades though no they and huge
titties that's no drive-thru and they
come out with roller blades wait which
Sonics has the huge titties in what's
that
about San Antonio it's drive-thru only s
s only a drivethru the Big Bloomers the
Dutch Bros model kind of no Victoria
Secret at sanor yeah I've never been to
a Dutch Bros that's not [__] popping
bro I went to the most popping one
recently I had no idea it was going to
be this freaking popping it was into uh
Oceanside and yo the line was like four
lanes fully backed up it looked like an
In-N-Out times like three D and it's
mainly coffee yeah but like they have
like other drinks like frozen slushy
fruit this it's a lot of dessert coffees
yeah dessert coffees so maybe that's the
exact demo that they're trying to Target
yeah could be is it is it a coffee place
no because like all right their main
drinks at they call them exotic sour
cherry energy slush that's what makes
you feel like Sonic tropical spice Aid
s'mores cold brew as well as edible
treats like MC pops pretzel bites Savory
hash brown bites and the spicy queso
sandwich these are like a lot of
signature things that are like the front
not McDonald's it feels like Starbucks
and Dutch Bros had a baby cut and
million milk she think about Savory hash
brown bites take like a McDonald's hash
brown cut them up in smaller bit
bits me bro tater tots if it's the same
tasting hash browns I would love those
and they got big te ladies coming out
that's big on roller blades in a driveth
big titty lady chasing your car as you
go through the drivethru they're they're
bouncing around come trying that's what
I miss is you know I wasn't a part of
this era but I would imagine that they
marketed beautiful ladies coming out and
working and stuff but like now you just
got like immigrants W just immigrants
immigrants are the inverse of beautiful
ladies yeah it's just so that's what it
looks like the first one is opened up in
Illinois doesn't look appetizing though
so they can't see it yeah that's a
throwback method you can see the the
golden arches in the corner so you know
it's a McDonald's franchise and it's
called
Cosmic I like the name how it's like to
very good I don't mind The Branding
either it looks like a like a I don't
know like a vintage soof or something I
mean it's not well from a business point
of view it's not meant to be the same as
like McDonald's they already have 40,000
Plus locations they're just trying to
cover an entirely different demographic
because they can you know what I mean
what's going to have to happen to
McDonald's when they just can't McDonald
anymore they have to make it's hard to
imagine a world without them man no I
mean like as in like they're like all
right we literally have a McDonald's in
Antarctica we can't McDonald anymore
there's no more locations right then
they have to Cosmic that's what they're
getting ready for I see look think about
this they got something called MC Pops
that come in three different flavors
cookie butter apple cinnamon and
hazelnut you can get a blueberry ginger
boost you can get a creamy avocado
tomatillo sandwich like there's just a
bunch of [__] so not coffee at all
there's a couple ones like that s'mores
coffee yeah there s'mores cold brew [__]
like thatof dud MFE is pretty solid
couple yeah look like Sonic he's right
it feels like so this is like it shows I
know this is very small but it shows
like Iced Teas and lemonades it shows
signature Galactic boost damn it's it's
like in Jamba territory Berry hibiscus
sour I'll tell you this there's nothing
jby about it there's a churro frap
churro frap don't push
him it doesn't know what it wants to be
yeah that's the thing it's like too many
things it's too many things turmeric
spice latte turmeric you gay hey do they
have Boba anywhere on there see now you
going into that like Health category no
whoa they're confused man dude they
lizards popping pear slush oh that's
their way of calling it Boba huh don't
don't hey honestly I'd be down to try it
though I'm down I'm down down boy I'd be
down to try it for sure I'll try it for
sure but but I don't like those drinks
though cuz I'm loyal to McDonald's but I
think they're trying to do too much like
if they did a coffee shop like a like a
maafe yeah something like that I think
that' be TI dedicated just forast no but
just like with all this other dedicated
Cafe but like what do you need it for
they already have the coffee at the
McDonald's I thought it was competing
with Starbucks this when someone told me
about it that's what McDonald's mcafe is
already trying to do but in Europe they
have a standalone M Cafe they have they
have espresso machines and they have
like pastries and stuff Cafe other
countries is different though and they
took McDonald's in other countries hit
different they took
[Laughter]
Bitcoin e flavored we were able to go to
the uh France McDonald's and then you
know the kiosk cuz they hate like
employees in France so then like when
you went and then you go would you like
a take a bigger Bitcoin that's how they
huh lightning
Network I heard Jad
clear I mean look if it's made by
McDonald's I'm down to try it I'll go
[__] find a random flavor or some
whatever you have you tried everything
at McDonald's
currently yeah yeah every single thing
you've had like all the fish I think all
the whenever there's like a like the MC
rib everything yeah that's pretty cool I
mean name it you tried every single
thing no not if you're going to say it
like that I haven't tried the ethereum
burger I had a MCB the other day I think
I've tried everything the MCB is back
don't [__] with me dog but you know what
though it's [__] up because it just
feels like they
assembled the MC rib like the worst way
possible it looks like they just threw
it in the [__] box dude like the
bottom it is back that's just America
that's America if it is what they're
really doing that makes it tight again
yeah like when I open d i open up it
look like just splatters everywhere and
I was like what the you just gave SAR
the way they make McDonald's in other
countries is
like Like a Surgeon done sure dropping
it from a ladder America's for show like
no do you think that like a manager goes
up to somebody who's like doing that
they put it down like that like why
aren't you
chucking why aren't you chucking yeah
put some velocity on that arm yeah let's
get
some side that
[__] I remember I got a six piece
chicken nuggets from McDonald's here and
then when I opened it it was a it was a
chicken patty just one real chicken
patty what that really happened to you
and I was like they're so high would be
on and then you check the and then you
check the bag the bag had the
bun as [__] it was just I was like dude
and they always [__] up and they're
always high like their eyes are just
bloodshot and they're like oh chicken
nugget uh you just ate it like that I
didn't even eat it I was just laughing
like I was like [__] dude you didn't I
had hamburgers and other stuff you
didn't reverse and go like hey what's up
with this and then they pull a gun on
you it was too late I was back at the
office Tac Bell oh my bad Taco Bell's
more ganga Taco balls are trash I've
seen a lot of those vids great it's like
it's like Starbucks though McDonald's is
like Starbucks where it's like there's
such a huge name in franchise that if
they throw out some attempt it's still
probably going to taste kind of good
it's interesting at least yeah yeah even
if it doesn't hit it's still kind of
going to be dank also In Our Lifetime
have they ever done something similar to
this no not in our lifetime that makes
it cool to me man when at Starbucks if
you're like hey so I ordered the Turkey
um uh sandwich thing with the egg whites
and there's no turkey bacon you know
what I mean the the employees aren't
like they're not like you know they're
like they're like I'll [__] Sue I'll
[__] sue you I have a lawyer and
you're like oh Jesus I don't want to
deal with I will say the first time
McDonald's ever did the McFlurries that
was like way out that was pretty M
flurry wow did you ever did you ever try
the mix salad shakers I did oh yeah you
remember them remember those you have to
shake it I tried it once and never got
it again or the chicken select the snack
wraps were sick though yeah snack wraps
snack they're I'm telling you McDonald's
they can very they can do very little
wrong they got crispy chicken now they
got the crispy chicken sandwiches that's
what they and they have the McChicken
too double they still do the southern
one that was good I still got that the
best thing they do period is in in
breakfast time they do the the the
sausage burritos oh I love those you
know I'm a McGriddles fan I like
McGriddles too sausage mles I get both
point of cosmics if only at cosmics they
make the fries with the original
lard do they really they need to bring
it back if they did if they did they
need to stop using canola oil I'll drive
out of
state I'll drive the
Florida do you think they'll ever like
you know how this whole movement of
no more seed oils like everyone's
switching oh I see like yeah like do you
think do you think it'll ever go back to
large well that's kind of I think
there's a slight chance because remember
how we were all about um what's it
called we were all doing Plastics on
paper and they were like no the trees
save the trees so we moved on to
Plastics and now they're like plastic
Save the Ocean Save the Ocean now we're
back to paper y I could see fries going
back to lard I'm telling youal see in
those Tik Tok videos about how like
McDonald's most Fries Are Made though is
like kind of sketch but I'm still down
for them they're delicious what you
talking about they're talking about the
type of potato that they need and the
way that they bleach them I and they
have to use like a toxic chemical on it
once in a while you're allowed a little
bit of plastic sure yeah eat it I'm just
saying see them it's like oh damn sket I
don't give a [__] if they coat it in
[__] yeah meth make it look better
paint it put nail polish on the fries
I'll eat it even nowadays when I see
those videos I'm like I don't even
believe this [__] either I don't believe
none of it dude yeah [__] pussy's
awesome yeah they would never do that to
me that's what I
say